[Music]
for like half an hour well first of all
I want to say before we get into this
the only reason Collider gets to be at
the Toronto Film Festival is because we
have great sponsors want to give you a
huge thank you to Nordstrom Canada and I
want to say if you want anything from
Nordstrom Canada I can probably make
that happen
I think someone from Nordstrom Canada is
here right now is there any other Moors
from Canada
can we just bring this interview and go
shopping hi hi Nordstrom Canada right so
anyway best return policy whatever right
I can make like I could I can make that
happen
so a huge thank you to North from Canada
for being the great sponsor and now
let's get into why I get to talk to you
so this is a hell of a year for you huh
oh my goodness yeah I bet about a year
ago when I was doing pressed for for
Jurassic I I sort of at that point it
was like okay I'm gonna be over the next
year year and a half before we shoot the
the following one I'm gonna be directing
full-time but I didn't know what was
going to necessarily be happening so I
knew about the mandalorian couldn't say
anything about the mandalorian so I knew
I was gonna be doing mandalorian but
dad's was something that was just kind
of like in its beginning sort of phases
of just sort of brainstorming and
figuring out what its gonna be and so so
it's yeah it's it's you know getting to
be here at the Toronto Film Festival is
such a huge honor and not anything that
like a year and a half ago I thought was
going to be coming to fruition sure if
I'm not mistaken I could be wrong but I
believe you shadowed your dad on solo
yes yeah and so I have to which is crazy
because at the time you couldn't have
known about mandalorian now and so but I
want to so you obviously have worked on
a million film sets and you have your
dad but a million I wish like so you've
been around the industry yes yeah yeah
so what was it like shadowing someone on
set like that and also being a Star Wars
movie like I mean it was it well what
was
really awesome about it was we were
actually we filmed Jurassic world in
Pinewood Studios in outside of London
and and simultaneously stola was being
shot and and so there were a lot of
people who were working on both crews I
mean it's like it's it's sort of lit
with like the Frank commercial Kathy
Kennedy like it's you know they feel
like cousins Steven Spielberg you know
George and his relationship with Steven
like the two movies Jurassic and Star
Wars just in my mind it's like I'm like
their first cousin sure and at least
that's how I've organized them in my
head and so uh and again like a lot of
the same visual artists a lot of you
know it's like they're they're living on
the same block I'm gonna stop with the
metaphors but uh but basically when when
Jurassic ended and my dad was gonna be
doing solo I just said like I'm calling
in the ultimate favor like I have to be
on that set and my dad was actually
little he was concerned because he was
like you know I don't is that gonna be
is that gonna make the other actors
comfortable is that appropriate will you
even be allowed to be on set and and I
was just really I was just really really
really persistent honestly and and I
just knew that this was like I just
wanted I just was yeah I was just
fanatical I like wasn't like totally
gracious and like I was like like I just
flew myself like out there like
constantly if I ever had to come back to
the States for something like I would
just I just had to be there as much as
possible one of the things though on a
movie like that I would imagine that you
you're you've never when you're acting
on a movie you're not really looking at
what you don't have time to really study
what the director is doing what did you
well maybe you did you're looking it's
all I do
I don't leave sad it's it's it's all
like I I if you look at kind of like if
you go back and look at some of the
awesome directors that I've had the
opportunity to work with like that was
all totally I mean not like I was like
oh I want to work with this person this
person this person but I had those
dreams like my agent is here didn't I
have a list when I was 19 years old
I noticed when I was 19 years old I was
just like oh my gosh these are the
people that I want to study under and
because I've always wanted to be a
director and so so it's just every
single set that was like I mean of
course my number-one responsibility was
to be of service to the director as the
storyteller you know as the Prez the
visionary behind the project and what
that looked like in my mind was like I'm
just always there just like I just you
know I want you studying lenses and
everything else yeah so your heart you
went hardcore I will actually for
instance one of the reasons why I was
excited to work with Lausanne
lars von trier was not just lars von
trier although I was very excited to
work with him his DP is a guy named
Anthony mantle and Anthony it was one of
the first cinematographers who were was
really really really kind of pushing
what was possible in terms of you know
cameras within the digital medium and so
like I was 22 years old when I did that
movie and I remember being like oh my
gosh like he's gonna be like I get to
talk to him and he had been working with
like Harmony Korine he was just he was
one of the like the dog 195 guys and I
loved dog my knife I referred like all
the time now I'm like oh like get me dog
another five right now but anyway so I I
remember like just cornering him on this
set and just being like what is
happening what are you gonna do about
the flicker effect like like how is this
medium going to evolve and kind of the
opposite version of that was on my first
movie was Roger Deakins who shot it and
Roger Deakins shot beautiful mind and so
I was just always on the side of your
mind Roger was here this morning what
something to tell you when the camera
stops right I can't wait I can't wait
but it was so it's it's the
cinematographers the directors other
actors I mean I just wanted to just be
in situations where creative people were
being courageous and daring and and
imaginative and just pushing things
forward you know so it's it's just been
but the I don't like to sit in my
trailer and when I'm wrapped I often do
not leave once I had kids like that
obvious something shifted to yeah
because kids are kids are a priority you
know but but before that point like when
it would when I would be done shooting
like there was no way that I was leaving
set and my dad talked about that a lot
too he was like go there on a day don't
just stay go there on a day when you are
not on the call sheet and you are you
can truly be an observer and you can
truly watch and no one feels like they
have to take care of you and then you're
gonna get a really good sense of
everything and so I always do that every
single movie I just realized so jumping
into you have a your film here is dads
everyone watching this interview will
most likely not have seen the movie yet
so let's do the generic what is it about
yeah okay what is it about dad sure okay
no dad's is a it's a feature documentary
it's a comedy and it's basically a
celebration and an exploration of what
it takes to be a father in today's world
and so the way it came about I started
it officially about a year a little over
a year ago and the company called
Unilever financed it and they have a
relationship with an institute in in
Brazil that is incredible because they
are doing remarkable work in the field
of masculinity fathering gender
stereotypes stigmas around men being
caregivers and all of that and they are
Pro it's called the pro mundo Institute
and I think I'm mispronouncing that and
so in his first meeting that I had with
them they were like yeah we're thinking
a feature film about fatherhood and
here's all this incredible research that
they've done and they had just released
white papers around specifically fathers
and and their involvement with children
early on in life because the assumption
is like oh the kids just with the mom
sure and and it couldn't be further from
the truth
how how impactful it can be for a father
to be involved so anyway
this meeting I was listening to all this
and I was like okay so the goal is
really to kind of I don't know shifts
the culture or fatherhood or maybe not
shift it but just acknowledge the shift
acknowledge the shift that's happened
around fatherhood in in the modern world
and and so I was like well parenting is
absurd and ridiculous and hilarious so
it's got to be a comedy I'm biased
because I grew up on the set of
parenthood which was a comedy and and so
I thought of you know all the wonderful
incredible comedians who like whenever
I'm talking with someone like I'm
typically asking them about their kids
like early on in the conversation and
and I love hearing dads talk about their
kids and so the idea of all of these
comedians sort of being like a Greek
chorus in between these profiles that I
could do on father's around the world
real fathers around the world that felt
really fun to me and and so and so
that's exactly what happened what I
didn't anticipate was halfway through
filming that my brother and his wife
would become pregnant with their first
child and so early on I had kind of
pitched a version where maybe there was
my I interviewed my dad you know maybe
my grandfather had passed away and I had
shot some footage of him in a project
that I directed for Vanity Fair a few
years prior I'd interviewed him about
the 1960s and I was like maybe there's
something in there like you know I could
go back and look my dad was like no no
no no no no but when I found out that my
brother was gonna have a kid and I was
looking for an expecting father I was
like I need a dad that I can film like
before he becomes a dad and then after
he becomes a dad like capture the rite
of passage basically and and so when
that happened I was like it's I'm sorry
dad's y'all are in this movie I can't
yet what you who was the toughest one to
get in this movie besides a family
member honestly the toughest people just
aren't in the movie like it was everyone
all of the comedian's
who were in the film it required no
convincing we didn't want to have to
convince anyone like it's it's they were
volunteering their time so
we were really really really lucky and
and honestly actually a little surprised
how many people responded and they were
like yeah we're available and excited to
do it and and awesome and so and so it
wasn't yeah none of the like it's like
the the the challenging thing was the
scheduling that was the challenging
thing but I was actually even really
surprised like the the easiest person to
say yes and the easier person to
schedule was Will Smith would you ever
think that no like he was just like yes
and he was like what you know like just
in great communication like I mean his
team and stuff and honestly all of the
comedian's were like that and all of the
people around them who supported them
with the schedule and whatnot really
facilitated this and I think I mean a
lot of what the comedian said afterwards
was that they had just never been asked
those questions that they were just not
well dad I'll be honest with you you say
it on my side on the on the reporter
side
I don't ever ask personal questions it's
not what I'm care more about the
filmmaking and like the filmmaking like
I don't care who people are dating I
don't ask about kids I don't do personal
calls yeah but the thing is I know that
there are many reporters who would love
to ask those questions but typically the
wall is up you know like I'm sure People
magazine would love to do a story on
Will Smith talking about his kids but
he'll never do that you see what I mean
so you had it you had a sneaky way being
who you are yes yeah and I think that
also it was yeah it's like disarming to
be to say you know I'm there's a
documentary that I'm doing and I'm
interviewing my father and my family is
involved and it's about modern
fatherhood and so it's like yeah cool
great you know um by the way I'm giving
you like it I'm not knocking I'm just
saying that there's like there's like a
wall that I put up that I won't ask
those questions totally you know what I
mean and I think that is something that
it requires a specific circumstance in
order to be able to kind of like have
that honest exchange completely and um
and it was I mean the set it's it's a it
was a fairly large set we would paint
the backdrop just like a different color
like the primary colors and so it's kind
of a big space sort of upbeat and they
would stand for the entire interview and
so it was because one of the more
stand-up comedians and they are so you
know physically kind of connected and
comedy is so physical I wanted to be
able to see the full performance and and
I think that when they when they worked
in like Judd Apatow said afterwards it's
like oh my gosh I interviewed him for
like two hours I think like oh my gosh I
just thought I was going to be coming in
here just like some questions about
fatherhood he was like when I do a
documentary I at least allow my subjects
to sit thing about it though is that I
think that it's hard when you're like
say your Will Smith and you're promoting
a movie it's hard to switch to your kids
and I'm sure even with you when you're
promoting like when you're gonna promote
Jurassic or whatever you know if someone
comes in and all the sudden wants to
spend half the interview talking about
your family I'm sure the wall goes up
for you because it's not really what
you're mentally prepared for yeah and I
think also there's this you know our
families are so like all we want to do
is protect them and every way possible
and and I think there's this kind of
like unspoken trust I mean you know what
this is actually how I feel like when I
go and I'm interviewed by like Conan
O'Brien or Fallon or Kimmel
name-dropping
do get interviewed like on one of those
shows there isn't understanding because
they are more iconic than me you know
they are huge celebrities that they get
like they're not gonna go there because
they've had to deal with whatever
negative repercussions come from living
a public life you know is the same way
as anyone else that there ain't also I
think I personally like said I'm I am
the wrong person but I personally
believe in that whole like you know
separation of like you know when I talk
to an actor I want to talk about the
acting and I want to talk about making
the movie everyone deserves a private
life yeah you know I think as well like
a lot of a lot of women are you know not
not by you because of you know your
philosophy around what you are there to
do and achieve in your interviews
but you know a lot of other
circumstances they do they will ask
women in particular about about
parenting and how does it takes to you
know what it takes to balance at all and
and that's those are not questions that
are asked of a father completely and and
so that that's what was so refreshing I
think we're getting to interview all
those guys because they were so like you
could see that there were no canned
answers like they they were really
having to generate these ideas perhaps
you know perhaps for the first time even
you know perhaps it was the first time
that they had articulated a specific a
memory or you know a parenting
philosophy or whatever and and that was
that was just that was exciting because
you felt like you're like oh my gosh we
were having a real conversation here and
and when you ask someone something and
they're like huh
you know that's you always know that
what will follow is is is authentic blue
so you did dads you then did mandalorian
you've been studying being a director
for a very long time what is coming up
what are you thinking about right now
and do you have something that you just
can't talk about yet oh sorry there
definitely something like oh there's
some things cooking that that I'm very
very very excited about for the future
because I've basically I mean just
common sense it's hard to get the first
thing but once you get the first thing
and can show somebody something
all of a sudden fine answers are like oh
wait no she can do it yeah yeah yeah
it's you know that's always kind of
that's that's the barrier that you want
to kind of break through you know anyone
and and that's why I just kept doing for
the last like 15 or so years a lot of
short films and short documentaries and
and music videos and just stuff like
that because I wanted to just keep
learning but also ultimately amass some
portfolio of sorts to be like hey like
you know you're not you're not betting
on a novice here or whatever you know
that's that's sort of the plan and and
and I I think that you know through that
sort of journey
I I was very attracted to emerging
technology and it was something that I
didn't necessarily expect because I
can't work my thumb I can't turn on my
television but like all I want to do is
talk about like stuff with John Favreau
and like how he did Lion King and you
know I mean like that's that is that
that is when I saw Jurassic Park for the
first time I was 12 years old by the way
Perry is sitting right there
that's her favorite movie i I feel very
similarly like that movie that how old
were you when you saw that movie no
that's young
that's very young that by the way
explains date with you rate explains a
lot about Perry I was 12 but I I was
older I was it was opening weekend of
when the movie came out and I remember
crying during the film not because I was
scared not because I was moved by the
story because of the technology because
the dinosaurs were real and I knew in
that moment it was kind of that like
overwhelm of oh my gosh what I'm feeling
like my reptilian part of my brain is
getting triggered in like this is a real
dinosaur but also the adrenaline and the
rush of oh my gosh what is possible in
storytelling right now when Jurassic
Park came out my dad was developing
Apollo 13 and he was getting ready to do
Apollo 13 and he went to Steven
Spielberg and he was like how do you
think I should do the weightlessness and
Steven mentioned to him this thing
called the vomit comet which is a plane
where you you know fly up and then drop
and you get 27 seconds of weightlessness
and I remember just during this time my
dad was just obsessively trying to
figure out how to achieve this -
watching watching Jurassic Park knowing
the mentorship that was happening
between Steven and my father and and
then also seeing my dad being powered by
this other filmmaker and actually do
that thing and use the Vomit Comet
incidentally after its he went to Steven
and he was like what did you do with the
weightlessness and right I was like
vomit comment no Steven was like what
you actually did
so so it was like I think I'm very close
to my dad I can't tell but um
so his his passions um were a lot of my
passions like I was also equally
passionate about like basketball because
my dad loved basketball so yeah you know
it was it's that's the kind of kid that
I was and so um so I think that it's
very it's shocking you wanted to be a
director
really how could that have happened
so now getting the chance to work with
with Jon Favreau and mandalorian and
Dave Filoni as well and and getting to
you know get deeper and deeper and
deeper into that world of what is
possible with cinema is I hope in some
way that my future is there you know it
is is that I'm getting to work in
alongside individuals who are really
pushing the medium forward and and
reaching for breakthroughs and and
telling beautiful and impactful stories
that elevate the medium that's what I
hope completely um I basically have to
go with you so I'm trying to think about
how I can I mean should I have a million
other questions but I guess I'm curious
about when will we find out more about
your episode of mandalorian I don't know
I know it's coming out November 12th
sure are you I mean that the series are
you wrapped on post or do you still have
to work on it
there's everything's on time it's good
things are going well we'll talk more
when I've seen the episode really I will
say is in it in the trailer that came
out there are quite a few shots I
watched it again and again and again
I should have filmed myself watching
that trailer by the way yes because
that's the kind of thing that goes viral
right especially with Star Wars for what
a mistake yeah by the way lesson learned
here's the thing that I've learned about
life and this is very important you can
and I swear I take this advice with me
every day
you can never be upset if you screw up
you can only be upset if you screw up
doing the same thing twice never be
upset if you screw up you can only be
upset if you screw up doing the same
thing twice yeah of course okay so never
be upset if you screw up if you haven't
done it before yeah I mean listen so you
didn't I like that you didn't think to
film yourself yeah but if you were to
happen to same film an episode of
mandalorian season 2 which hopefully you
are maybe you can say something right
now not if you are I can't and I'm just
being blank because I can't say anything
either way they're doing mandalorian
season 2 but I'm saying if you were to
happen to do another episode of
something you should then film yourself
watching the trailer for the first time
that's a good idea no I'm gonna do that
I'm just gonna film myself I'm just I'm
just good for myself constantly sure on
that note
Susie Congrats on being part of the
Toronto Film Festival and I cannot wait
to see the film and to see mandalorian
thank you so much